we know what things are uh largely by
what they're for right that's the
distinction between like like if I I
have a microphone here let's say I had a
bigger microphone I had like a you know
a rockstar
microphone and I you might ask me
Michael what is that in your hand I
would say well uh it's a microphone what
distinguishes this microphone in my hand
from some other similarly looking object
that I could I could hold in my hand for
instance I could use the microph phone
to hang a painting on the wall right I
could use it and I could hammer a nail
into my wall and it would probably
Hammer the nail probably wouldn't do a
very good job at it but it would hammer
the nail it probably break the
microphone if I did that so I I could
use the microphone for that purpose but
it would it would be a better ordered it
would be a better use of the microphone
to use it for for ampf would you out
would you outlaw using it for hammering
it into a wall well I uh not necessarily
but if it redounded in the murder of a
child I probably would